ムーシュー
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
いやーすごく良い物件ですね今月いいとネット込みで3万円でしたっけ
はいそうですじゃあここにしますあっありがとうございます
やすごく良い物件ですね4万円の中に今でツイートネット入ってます
入ってないです行法合わせて1万円ぐらいになります
5万円弱か
まあでもいい部屋だしな
ここにしますあっありがとうございます
5万円弱か
まあでもいい部屋だしな
黒にしますありがとうございますそれではまず米金が家賃の2ヶ月分であります
平均後敷金が1カ月分を塗りますし危険グリーティング代が1ヶ月同杯+水道代火災
保険管理費
ちょっとペット大京駅24時間安心サポート後駐車所
存在日
免許取ったら何かをかねぇ
dtr やっぱかっこいいな旧モデルの中古50万円か
頑張ろうん
免許取ったら何かをかねぇ
ダイハツの軽を燃費がいいな
中古で100万円か
今頃
でも自動車学校30万円ミンギョ交付の手続きがにもんいっぱい初の車検も入れて+中
も
この場所おりへの取ったあったは今ぬん
財布なくしちゃったーーーーめんどくせー
うーん財布なくしちゃったーーーーめんどくせー
大丈夫だよ警察にどこ行ったらおそらくもどって来るや運とんじゃあ行ってみようか
ねぇ
うーん
あー財布なくしちゃったーーーー面倒ぞ
をありがとう
年収が300万円になりますまた6月と12月に1か月分のボーナスかでます
決まって出るんですかねそれなら年収を350万円にした方がいいんじゃないですか
このやり方だと某ナース大耐えるか
形になりますどっちみちでるんだったら代わりに基本年収を出すなります
そもそも棒がオーナーす
にゃ tpp のおかげでやっとチーズバーガーも安くクエリオンだったな
ねいいね豚もん
にゃ tpp のをかけてやっとチーズバーガーも安く増えるようになったな
ねいいねんもう国内産ってやっぱ最高だよね
っていうか tpp って何んいや俺もわからんけど
うん
にゃ tpp のをかけてやっとチーズバーガーも安く買えるようになったな
ねぇいいねぇ
そういえばこれどこの肉アメリカだよ
なった
ラッテっ
与えシべ抱き合った毒が回ってきたな
そういう北に行くと思うと妻ヨシ
9あっっ
やチーズバッグチーズバーガーのおかげで tpp も安くいるのだと言う